[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans auditions
publiques une heure un invité tous les
lundis soirs à 19h30 sur public c'est
naï LCP soyez donc les bienvenus notre
invité ce soir c'est Marc fenaud bonsoir
à vous marchez merci d'être avec nous
ministres de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire la sécheresse
qui Séville les pesticides sur lesquels
vous avez plaisanter récemment au Sénat
mais qui sont un sujet majeur pour les
producteurs le bio en berne les prises
alimentaires en hausse la réforme des
retraites des décrets sont parus hier
est-ce un bras d'honneur aux manifestant
de demain vous nous le direz
l'atmosphère à l'Assemblée nationale
est-elle respirable Brigitte Boucher est
un train de nuit reviendront sur ses
enjeux dans quelques instants Vincent
roux sur les questions d'actualité Yves
trèsart sur la suite du quinquennat
marcéno sans majorité absolue êtes-vous
condamné à naviguer à vue Emmanuel
Macron est-il peut-il mener des réformes
avez-vous la réponse à cette question
évidemment pour la suite du mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron tout cela sont des
questions sur lesquelles on va revenir
je voudrais quelques instants d'abord en
introduction revenir avec vous sur cette
divergence entre Elisabeth borne et
Emmanuel Macron sur la meilleure façon
de lutter contre le rassemblement
national pourquoi parce que la première
ministre avait estimé publiquement que
le parti de Marine Le Pen était
l'héritier de Pétain le président a
dilué en conseil des ministres la morale
en substance la morale n'est pas
efficace pour convaincre les électeurs
mais je le cite dans le texte on ne
combat pas l'extrême droite avec les
mots des années 90 sur le fond c'est une
question importante c'est une question
importante sur le fond quelle est la
bonne stratégie celle du président ou
celle de la première ministre ne me dit
pas les deux mon capitaine parce que les
deux ne sont pas les mêmes mais c'est
les deux ne répondent pas aux mêmes
questions
la première ministre pardon je vous
faire ma réponse quand même les deux ne
répondaient pas à la même question la
première ministre Elisabeth borne a
répondu à une question d'un de vos
confrères sur radiologie qui était de
dire est-ce que vous pensez
qu’historiquement le Front National et
l'héritier du rassemblement national et
l'héritier du Front national lui-même
fondé par un certain nombre de gens qui
étaient des héritiers de Pétain ou qui
avait été dans l'héritage de Pétain et à
cette question elle répond oui comme
tout le monde peut répondre oui c'est un
fait historique ce faisant elle relie
historiquement c'est comme ça que le
fondateur du Front national c'était
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est Jean-Marie Le
Pen Jean-Marie Le Pen il avait dans ses
équipes des gens qui étaient les
héritiers pour une part d'entre eux de
ça c'est dans les fondateurs dans les
mondes fondateurs il y a des gens qui
avaient été militants si je peux dire de
cette de cette cause là donc la première
ministre répond à cela qui est un fait
historique et qu'il faut jamais oublier
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que au fond finalement sur ces
questions là il faut jamais
penser que parce qu'on changerait
d'habits il y a pas derrière pour
certains en tout cas des gens qui se
réclameraient ou qui derrière aurait
cette philosophie là la deuxième
question c'est de savoir comment combat
non seulement les idées mais la
progression du rassemblement national
dans les dans les urnes et dans les
voies et là c'est la question de la
façon dont s'adresse aux électeurs ce
qui est une autre question et le
président de la République a eu raison
de rappeler que s'adresser aux électeurs
c'est pas quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs et
quel que soit l'endroit où il se situe
quel que soit leur vote ce n'est pas de
leur donner des leçons et ce n'est pas
ce qu'elle fait Elisabeth vous étiez au
Conseil alors en plus alors vous n'y
étiez pas j'étais en conseil de
l'agriculture à Bruxelles vous avez le
droit c'est votre métier mais simplement
évidemment que de faire fuer cette
admonestation d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'égard d'Elizabeth borde c'était bien
pour souligner quand même qu'il y avait
une différence d'âge
je suis coutumier des conseils des
ministres ou ce n'est pas le la
présidence de la République qui fuite
c'est parfois des gens qui sont autour
de la table et qui pensent qu'il faut
fêter moi j'ai pour principe
de ne pas faire fuiter les débats et les
ce qui se dit au Conseil des ministres
c'est le lieu où on doit pouvoir dire
des choses
et sans que ce soit de nature publique
et donc je trouve que il y a aucun
intérêt à faire fuer ce genre de choses
donc je ne peux pas les propos tels qui
sont et deuxièmement sur le fond je vous
ai répondu il me semble que la question
fondamentale c'est d'essayer de
retrouver de l'apaisement dans le pays
on en reparlera tout à l'heure c'est la
question de répondre à ceux qui vont
parfois vers les votes populistes à
l'extrême gauche ou à l'extrême droite
et ce à qui faut répondre des sujets qui
sont les leurs cela dit Emmanuel Macron
qui dit comment qu'il faut lutter contre
le rassemblement national
avec un quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron le
rassemblement national n'a pas cessé de
monter donc en termes d'efficacité il
n'est pas le meilleur j'ai suffisamment
d'expérience politique ou d'ancienneté
politique depuis 84 le rassemblement
national il n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter
donc on doit tous se mettre en cause et
je pense que le sujet principal c'est le
sentiment que un n'écoute pas ou sans on
ne verbalise pas ce que vivent les gens
le deuxième sujet c'est d'essayer de
résoudre les sujets et je crois que
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire plus
5 ans mais je prends un seul exemple
quand vous êtes sur la question de
l'hôpital qui a autant de retard
accumulés sur la question de la médecine
libérale François Beaune si a-t-elle
comme si prédécesseurs aussi quand vous
libérez le numerus clausus vous avez des
effets à 9 ans quand vous décidez de
mettre 9 milliards c'était sous Jean
Castex sur le Ségur de la santé vous
résonnez à 3 4 5 ou 6 ans et donc il
faut qu'on accepte aussi que
rétablir un certain nombre de choses en
particulier dans ce domaine par exemple
de la santé ça prend du temps et c'est
ça qu'il faut qu'on explicite aussi la
politique est un temps long et
conforte assez mal les chaînes
d'information continue ou la demande
continue Twitter alors quand même cette
petite coeur à la distance en tout cas
c'est comme ça qu'elle a été perçue
l'émetteur est toujours un peu
responsable de la perception des faits
évidemment à entraîner beaucoup de
commentaires je vous cite celui-là de
Alexis Corbière député la France
insoumise sur LCI il a estimé je vais le
dire en terme cru Emmanuel Macron est un
lâche il s'essuie sur les pieds de
madame borne ce qu'il a tort bien écoute
humilié de comment dirais-je de l'excès
des propos il a un sur le fond tort et
de
il n'est jamais avare de de mots qui
sont des mots qui sont disproportionnés
et qui ne relèvent pas du champ
politique me semble-t-il de Monsieur
Corbière comme les autres devraient
faire attention aux mots qu'il emploie
parce que c'est inexact sur le fond et
c'est une approprié sur la forme
comme ça c'est un jurieux bien sûr il
peut y avoir il est coutumé le fait que
le premier ministre la première ministre
le président de la République puisse
avoir des débats mais dire cela c'est un
défaut de vérité par ailleurs c'est des
mots qui sont des moins juris je précise
qu'Emmanuel Macron interrogé il y a
quelques minutes au Mont Saint-Michel à
l'occasion d'un déplacement sur cette
querelle alors supposée je le dis quand
même parce que il répond que c'est du
clapotis du clapotis pardon et que ce
sont des bulles de savon sur lesquels il
ne veut pas
s'arrêter
de fond je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
parce que je veux dire mais commenter
des phrases auxquelles personne
n'insister essayez de nourrir
d'écureuils il me semble qu'on ressent
effectivement plutôt du clapotis que du
fond le remaniement ça n'est pas du
clapotis ça consomme ça concerne et tout
à l'heure extraire vous interrogera sur
le maintien ou non d'Elizabeth borne à
Matignon dans les semaines
pré remaniement pour remaniement
est prévenu de la façon dont vous allez
l'aborder je vous présente mais vous les
connaissez Brigitte boucher voilà
pour le Sénat et évidemment on commence
par la grande affaire des retraites elle
revient dans la rue demain exactement
nouvelle journée de mobilisation donc
demain l'intersyndicale ne désarme pas
Sophie Binet la secrétaire général de la
CGT juge que je la cite rien est écrit
d'avant ça l'estime que les suites
dépendants du niveau de mobilisation
est-ce qu'elle a tort
je pense pas que les choses doivent se
dire comme ça d'abord faut toujours
respecter les mobilisations et vous
m'avez jamais entendu dire autre chose
qu'il faut écouter ce qui peut se dire
dans la rue on verra ce qui est l'état
de la mobilisation demain à la sujet
désormais c'est de faire en sorte que la
réforme qui a été votée puisse dérouler
vous on viendra peut-être sur les
décrets d'application elle a été votée
dans la temporalité de l'année 2023 pour
qu'elle puisse s'appliquer dès le
premier septembre pour un certain nombre
de mesures il est pas illogique que nous
déroulions les choses ça n'empêche pas
qu'il faut qu'on continue le travail
d'explication la mobilisation de demain
elle peut changer les choses pour vous
selon son importance il y a pas de
mobilisation ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas l'écouter mais la nécessité pardon
est-ce qu'il y a besoin de de réformer
le système de retraite aujourd'hui il y
a 6 mois où il y a 12 mois la vérité
c'est oui c'est à dire que la
mobilisation ne change rien il y a pas
de retrait envisageable de la réforme on
peut pas en permanence gouverner c'est
pas la question du gouverner ça n'est
pas simplement la question d'être
populaire la question de gouverner c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on a de quoi on a besoin
comme réforme responsabilité pour le
pays on parle on passe notre temps on va
en parler
demain on passe notre temps
à parler de souveraineté la première des
souverainetés c'est de ne pas dépendre
des autres pour se financer et donc
d'avoir de temps vers des équilibres
budgétaires cette réforme elle vise à ça
avec un certain nombre d'autres mesures
qui viennent aussi améliorer la
situation qui est celle d'aujourd'hui de
ceux qui vont partir à la retraite et
donc qu'on puisse écouter les
manifestants qu'on puisse écouter la
colère mais qu'on puisse dire aussi sans
être insultant l'endroit de personnes
qu'on pense que cette réforme est
nécessaire c'est pour ça qu'on l'a voté
y compris
au risque de l'impopularité avec le
chemin que nous avons fait je pense que
il faut que cette réforme désormais
puisse se dire alors justement les deux
premiers décrets d'application sont
parus hier au Journal officiel avec
notamment la mesure la plus controversée
contre laquelle se battent les
manifestants celles qui concerne le
report de l'âge légal est-ce que ce
n'est pas provocateur en cette semaine
de mobilisation dans la rue à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte il a été
voté il est passé sous les fourches
collines s'ils vont permettre
l'expression du Conseil constitutionnel
et au motif qu'il y avait un impact
budgétaire en 2023 il a été mis dans un
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça en partie que le
Conseil constitutionnel de la validité
puisqu'il y avait des mesures ça rentre
puisse se mettre en oeuvre dès le mois
de septembre nous sommes le 5 juin n'est
pas illogique que nous fassions en sorte
sauf à avoir
mentielle
vous l'auriez fait à la fin de la
semaine après le parcours hypocrite
avant une mobilisation avec lequel
j'aborde toujours ces sujets là il y a
aucune offense qui est faite à personne
simplement les décrets d'application il
y a une temporalité il y a des choses à
préparer on est au mois de juin il faut
que ça soit promotrice c'est pas une
offense sur un texte qui est voté qui
est voté qui est définie
non le texte celui-là il est
définitivement voté donc
c'est une notion de censure parce qu'il
y a une motion de censure sur le texte
on avance parce qu'il y a encore un
épisode parlementaire la proposition de
loi du groupe liotte qui vise à abroger
la réforme des retraites qui va être
discuté jeudi dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a cet article
1 avec un amendement de suppression qui
a été adopté qui a été voté adopté en
commission et qui vise donc à supprimer
le retour à la retraite à 62 ans
le groupe lot a déposé un amendement de
rétablissement c'est-à-dire pour que on
puisse revenir à la retraite à 62 ans
est-ce que vous souhaitez que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
fasse jouer l'article 40 de la
construction et juge cet amendement il
recevable sur le plan financier moi je
n'ai pas d'injonction à donner à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
été ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement simplement je dis ce que j'ai
dit il y a six semaines
c'est que manifestement l'article 1 il
vient il vient ajouter une charge
complémentaire au budget de l'État ou
une perte de recettes ça dépend des
façons dont on peut le lire et que
l'article 40 prévoit que dans ce cas là
c'est irrecevable vous n'êtes pas sûr
qu'il brand Pivet brandissent la
question vous n'êtes pas sûr à ce stade
je n'ai pas dit ça du tout je dis juste
que je ne viens pas donner des leçons on
a l'impression quand même que le
gouvernement a tortu le bras à la
présidente nationale non je ne crois pas
je ne crois pas ça du tout elle a changé
elle n'a pas pris là
vous trouverez pas sur le terrain
d'aller donner une injonction au
Parlement parce que c'est la règle il
faut qu'on essaie de respecter des
injonctions peut-être quand vous étiez
non non
jamais reçu l'injonction j'ai essayé de
convaincre parfois sur certains sujets
j'ai essayé de trouver des équilibres
pour que des textes puissent passer de
faire qui est un dialogue entre la
majorité et le gouvernement parfois
entre la majorité l'opposition et le
gouvernement ça c'est le boulot du
mrpable
si vous lisez la Constitution
structurellement si ce texte était voté
avec un article 1 comme il est rédigé et
qu'il était au Conseil constitutionnel
le Conseil constitutionnel le suçant le
censurer un seul motif le motif de
l'application de l'article 40 alors vous
avez peut-être lu le journal Le Monde il
y a une tribune de Charles de Courson
donc qui est député du groupe liote et
qui porte cette proposition de loi qui
est soutenu par l'ensemble de la nuque
et dans cette tribune il y a écrit que
la jurisprudence veut que l'examen se
fasse sur la base de référence la plus
favorable à l'initiative par le monde
est-ce que vous reconnaissez que cette
irrecevabilité de cette proposition de
loi elle n'est pas dans la pratique
parlementaire
l'article 40 il a déjà été invoqué sur
un certain nombre beaucoup moins sur des
propositions là on est sur un amendement
oui pardon il y a eu un vote en
commission qui a supprimé l'article il y
a un amendement qui relève de l'article
40 voilà c'est tout de balayer cette
position je vais vous dire il y a
quelque chose sur le fond au-delà
je vous lis le texte parce que c'est
important il est de jurisprudence
constante que cet examen se fasse sur la
base de référence la plus favorable à
l'initiative parlementaire très bien
alors il est je rappelle que Charles de
Courson disait pour le QG pour lequel
j'ai plutôt grand respect parce que je
l'ai connu dans d'autres temps et en
d'autres lieux et servant d'autres
causes à la vérité y compris des
équilibres budgétaires mais peu importe
on a le droit de changer
dans sa vie il nous expliquait aussi que
par nature le Conseil constitutionnel
allait censurer le texte parce qu'il y
avait des tas de motifs de censure il a
été même à l'initiative de la de
renvoi au Conseil constitutionnel du
texte avec d'autres le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas jugé donc je
laissais les constitutionnalisme
attendez laissons les
constitutionnalisés et ça n'est pas la
lecture que je fais je suis pas sûr que
Charles de Courson puisse avoir une
lecture qui puisse s'opposer
par leur vote et c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel ou la Constitution en
tant que telle par parce qu'elle propose
et ce qu'elle dit y compris dans la
jurisprudence ça a été exprimé et sur le
fond on voit bien qu'il y a un sujet
parce que la question qui est posée par
ailleurs les initiatives vous le savez
très bien il faut qu'on prenne souvent
si vous ouvrez la boîte à des niches
parlementaires en permanence qui
viennent rajouter 15 milliards 20
milliards 30 milliards à la fin c'est
collectivement les responsabilité qui
règne parce que si le sujet il suffit
juste de dire j'augmente la taxe sur les
tabacs d'abord je lis à ceux qui sont
consommateurs de tabac ce que je ne
conseille pas mais le on dit quelque
chose qui est faux aux Français et la
seule question qui a posé me semble-t-il
y compris à Charles de Courson c'est
comment on équilibre le système de
retraite simplement ce que vous possédez
la drogation vous n'auriez pas préféré
qu'il y ait un vote au moins un seul
vote sur tout le parcours parlementaire
de cette réforme des retraites alors
effectivement il aurait pu être
défavorable pour le gouvernement mais au
moins le Parlement aurait pu supprimer
ça n'aurait pas été finalement plus ce
que je regrette c'est que l'esprit de
responsabilité et échapper un certain
nombre de gens je parle pas à des gens
de la nups pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui qui courent derrière la
dépense sans avoir la moindre conscience
de ce que ça peut produire pour les
Français parce que si vous n'êtes pas
capable de rembourser votre dette c'est
pas les plus riches qui sont les plus
pénalisés c'est les plus pauvres quand
vous regardez ce qui s'est passé dans
les pays qui ont fait défaut sur leur
dette ou qui ont eu des taux d'intérêts
contre montrés ça n'a jamais été les
plus riches qui ont été pénalisés ça a
toujours été les plus pauvres et donc
j'aurais plutôt espéré qu'on ait un
esprit de responsabilité ceci dit je
considère que il y a eu 49-3 c'est une
procédure parlementaire et il y a eu un
vote sur le 49 alors oui on continue à
parler quand même Conseil
constitutionnel et réforme des retraites
parce que le Groupe liote Bertrand
pencher a annoncé qu'il saisirait le
Conseil constitutionnel parce qu'il n'y
a pas eu de justement de vote sur la
réforme des retraites est-ce que c'est
quand même quelque chose que que vous
craignez déjà été saisi le Conseil
constitutionnel le Conseil
constitutionnel a rendu son avis sur la
réforme des retraites y compris sur le
fond est-ce que c'est un texte dans
l'application ça revient à nos décrets
et bien pour 2023 il a censuré un
certain nombre de mesures considérant
qu'il ne devait pas être dans ce texte
il a été dans son rôle et le Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé sur la procédure
alors je veux bien qu'en permanence on
essaie de refaire les débats et les
matchs mais ce pays a besoin de
stabilité de cap et je pense pas qu'on
sert cette cause-là
et puis par ailleurs pardon les mêmes
qui nous expliquaient que 15 jours ou
trois semaines n'était pas suffisant
pour se traiter de ce sujet éminent de
retraite on a quand même fait plus de 15
jours de débat à l'Assemblée nationale
beaucoup d'heures un temps ainsi
significatif au Sénat vient de vous
expliquer qu'en une journée on peut
traiter la question la réforme
rien et après on verra ben non quand on
est un responsable public on doit aussi
trouver les solutions pour équilibrer le
système c'est pas ce qu'on a sous les
yeux on gagnerait tous être responsable
je vous assure que dans ce pays on
gagnerait tous être responsable même si
c'est parfois avec la charge de
l'impopularité alors la sécheresse oui
alors après une année de sécheresse un
peu hors norme il a récemment plu est-ce
que cette pluie à améliorer la situation
est-ce que les nappes phréatiques se
sont remplies ou est-ce que la situation
est encore dans un une situation un peu
catastrophique aujourd'hui c'est d'abord
c'est assez disparate globalement il a
plutôt moi de janvier plutôt plus vieux
février très sec mars avril plutôt
pluvieux et en mai plutôt sur le sud
pour le coup qui était notre sujet de
préoccupation plutôt de la pluie ça ne
fera pas remonter le niveau des nappes
simplement ça empêche parce que le
niveau des nappes les se remplissent à
l'automne à partir du mois d'octobre
jusqu'au mois de février mars ou plus
tard on dit début avril pour ce qui est
des nappes profondes en particulier où
les autres nappes donc ça ne fera pas
remonter le niveau des nappes en
revanche ça permet d'éviter d'avoir
recours à l'irrigation d'avoir des
tensions sur l'alimentation en eau
potable et donc ça permet dans certains
territoires mais ne faisons pas
d'homogénéité parce que je pense en vous
parlant à la situation du bassin
méditerranéen en particulier
Pyrénées-Orientales Aude ou héros ou la
pluie qui tombe n'est pas suffisante
aujourd'hui pour couvrir le besoin et où
les agriculteurs en particulier mais
d'autres aussi sont dans des situations
de très grandes fragilité quels sont les
départements de départements qui sont
touchés en fait aujourd'hui alors après
il y en a qui sont vigilance mais c'est
un process normal que de mettre en
vigilance je reviens de la Gironde et de
Charentes où les départements sont en
situation de vigilance vigilance ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on essaie de
de modérer de mettre en vigilance tout
le monde sur les sur les usages de l'eau
mais on n'est pas encore en situation de
crise ou de crise exceptionnelle et donc
il y a cinq six départements qui se font
l'objet d'une attention particulière sur
le bassin méditerranéen il y en a un peu
plus qui sont en situation de vigilance
mais
on va pas découvrir aujourd'hui que
chaque année les préfets procèdent à des
situations de vigilance et crise le
sujet c'est à la fois de gérer cette
crise là et en particulier les quatre
quelques départements qui sont très
durement touchés j'étais l'autre jour
chez un viticulteur
responsable des vignerons indépendants à
Fitou dans l'autre il était tombé 95 mm
en 1 an en 13 mois sans irrigation
possible 95 mm en un an c'est la vigne
elle-même qui risque de disparaître sur
des sur des vignes et donc là on a
quelque chose à regarder de ce qu'on
peut faire tout de suite et puis le
sujet principal c'est de regarder dans
le long terme quels sont les systèmes
qu'on va rendre les plus résilients
possibles pour faire face à des épisodes
de sécheresse ou d'inondations
d'ailleurs en tout cas Nina climatique
qui va rendre l'agriculture plus fragile
si on parle des conséquences sur les
particuliers par exemple est-ce que dans
le département des Pyrénées-Orientales
par exemple il y a plus de piscine hors
sol depuis le 10 mai c'est interdit
est-ce que ça va se poursuivre s'étendre
à d'autres départements
oriental et ça s'étendra en fonction de
ces Christophe
mais
j'ai du mal à répondre à cette question
là parce que je ne sais pas la météo là
de 15 jours s'il tombe 100 mm alors on
annonce plutôt encore de l'eau
la semaine prochaine ou les 15 jours qui
viennent au sud je répète ça va pas
remplir les nappes ça évitera et ça
permettra de retrouver quelques étiages
dans les cours d'eau mais on a un été
difficile à passer sur ces régions là et
sur les autres il faut quand même qu'on
ait une pluviométrie désormais c'est
dans le Nord qui manque qu'on manque
d'eau il y a trois semaines on pouvait
pas planter c'est quoi le mauvaise météo
la vérité c'est une mauvaise météo c'est
une météo qui dure trop longtemps c'est
trop de secs trop d'eau etc donc on a
besoin de raisonner sur le court terme à
des mesures comme celles qu'on fait sur
les piscines que tout le monde doit être
appelé à faire son effort il était
incompréhensible que on dit vous
agriculteurs des Pyrénées-Orientales
vous devez faire un effort sur
l'irrigation parfois avec des
interdictions sèches
et puis qu'on dise on continue à remplir
les piscines pour nos loisirs il faut
que chacun fasse sa part de l'effort et
je pense que c'est vous voyez bien avec
la façon dont je le dis il faut arrêter
de jeter le montrer du doigt les uns les
autres je ne jette pas le mets pas le
doigt sur ceux qui ont des piscines ou
des piscines gonflables ou les campings
de telle ou tel endroit qui ont besoin
qui ont utilisé l'eau ni les
agriculteurs faut juste que chacun en
raison dise je dois faire ma part c'est
comme ça qu'on essaiera de mieux
anticiper les situations qu'on connaît
alors on va parler également pesticides
marques fenault il y a une séquence qui
a été tournée au Sénat par le média
vakita qui fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux on va la regarder
alors vous avez plaidé l'ironie sur
cette séquence est-ce que c'est très
habile de parler de façon ironique dans
le contexte actuel de recourir à ce
registre alors que c'est un enjeu très
sensible que celui des pesticides vous
voyez vous avez un très beau modèle je
n'ai pas envie de commenter longtemps
parce que les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
la vie normale j'ai pas très envie de
commenter longtemps une vidéo qui est
sortie de son contexte parce qu'il y a
pas le match aller ou votre consœur et
votre confrère m'avait badiné sur le
même thème en disant vous êtes le
défenseur de tel modèle moi je reprends
pas leur propos parce que mais c'était
sur le temps de la de la plaisanterie
auquel j'ai répondu par une plaisanterie
bon résultat des courses on monte en
épingle quelque chose comme si moi
ministre de l'Agriculture citoyen engagé
j'avais une autre stratégie que celle
que je déploie tous les jours qui est
celle de d'essayer de réduire les
pesticides alors que certains essaient
de monter en épingle de ce sujet parce
que
[Musique]
j'ai dit c'est terminé faut qu'on trouve
des alternatives et qu'on trouve des
sujets donc ne venons pas se faire des
forêts
et que je disais alors pardon je disais
une chose qui était simple je disais
est-ce qu'on a des alternatives
aujourd'hui généralisables la réponse
est non on est sur un bon chemin et donc
on a besoin de la 3e année dérogation
parce que c'était ce qui avait été voté
dans la loi c'était l'engagement qu'on
avait pris collectivement il y a une
décision de la Cour de justice je
l'applique et je ne dérange pas et quand
au sujet du S métaux l'accord c'est
marrant comme on n'arrive pas à dire des
choses assez une seconde vous savez que
tout à l'heure et vous avez accepté le
principe du débat avec un sénateur qui
va socialiste qui va vous interroger
longuement sur les pesticides on a
encore une question au moins à vous
poser Brigitte
alors on va parler du bio du coup on va
passer au bio sans pesticides les
conclusions de l'Agence Bio la semaine
dernière montrait une baisse de 6% des
ventes qui est quand même assez
important vous avez présenté un plan à
200 millions d'euros est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que c'est suffisant
pour une filière qui est très mal en
point on a plusieurs sujets on a une
baisse de consommation qui est liée à la
fois l'inflation avec un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens qui ne peuvent plus
accéder donc une baisse en gamme en fait
certains en gamme de prix notamment d'un
certain nombre de produits on a deux
volets une aide d'urgence de 60 millions
qui vient se rajouter au 10 millions qui
avait été indiqué déjà par la première
ministre et de ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
soutiennent la demande le sujet n'est
plus l'offre je rappelle qu'on a doublé
les surfaces attendez qu'on a doublé les
surfaces en agriculture biologique sous
le quinquennat précédent d'Emmanuel
Macron donc je veux bien que tous ces
gens-là viennent nous donner des leçons
mais nous nous avançons qu'on a donné un
objectif de passer de 10% si quelqu'un
aujourd'hui à 18% des surfaces
aujourd'hui les gens ne veulent plus
acheter cela comment vous faites
accessible vous ne créez pas le débouché
à coup de centaines de millions de
milliards pour créer du débouché il faut
qu'on fasse ce que je ces dialogues
qu'on aura avec l'Agence Bio qui dépend
de l'état c'est une agence de l'État
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on ait une
communication qui soit plus proactive
pour montrer l'intérêt du bio et y
compris ce qu'on n'a pas vu à l'époque
parce que la baisse du bio la
consommation de l'eau est date de la
covid pourquoi parce que sous covid on a
beaucoup développé les uns et les autres
d'ailleurs les circuits courts les
circuits de proximité bio ou
conventionnelles et donc on a besoin de
si vous permettez c'est que de redire en
quoi le bio lui-même est un produit de
proximité
est-ce qu'il faut pas mettre de l'argent
dans des aides alimentaires au bio
c'est pas forcément une question de de
c'est une question de prix pour un
certain nombre de Français qui vont pas
les moyens c'est une question d'image
collective qu'on doit porter le bio
c'est pas forcément plus cher ça dépend
ça dépend des catégories c'est pas
forcément plus cher deuxièmement il faut
que la grande distribution pourquoi sur
les produits bio la marge produite par
l'agrand distribution est plus grande
que sur les produits conventionnels
c'est une bonne question parce qu'après
tout si on veut soutenir on devrait
faire la même marche parce qu'une tomate
bio une tomate conventionnelle pourquoi
la marge est plus importante sur le bio
parce que on s'est mis dans la tête que
c'était un produit qui était adressé qui
a des gens qui avaient les moyens
et donc c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire ce
qu'il faut dire c'est à la fois
l'intérêt qu'il y a à développer le bio
en France il y a d'autres modèles mais
le bio est un modèle intéressant et le
deuxième sujet c'est d'essayer de
stimuler la demande en essayant
d'expliquer ce que c'est et donc on le
fait il faut que l'État soit exemplaire
60 ou 70 millions d'aide d'urgence et
deuxième élément pardon chez nous parce
que c'est important c'est de stimuler la
demande par la commande publique dans
les camps
la commande publique de l'État parce que
moi je viens pas donner des leçons aux
autres déjà faut que l'État applique
dans ses propres cantines dans sa propre
restauration la loi egalimat
au niveau national on est à 7% sur le
bio donc on doit atteindre les 20 mais
là
c'est ce que je vous dis c'est à peu
près dans la moyenne nationale et donc
on a
essayons de moi je ne fais là le son à
personne c'est compliqué parce qu'il
faut trouver que les prestataires le
fasse et donc on a besoin nous au niveau
de l'état de faire cet effort puis après
sans donner l'accent aux collectivités
locales que c'est un effet
d'entraînement sur les collectivités
locales parce que les 120 millions de
demandes supplémentaires qu'on met sur
la table pour la commande publique c'est
la commande publique de l'État mais
après il y a tout le reste de la
commande publique qui peut aussi
stimuler le bio il faut stimuler la
consommation bio c'est comme ça qu'on
s'en sortira merci beaucoup Brigitte et
Ethan dans un instant évidemment
ifstraire van nous rejoindre mais
d'abord on rejoint en direct du Figaro
live Vincent roux bonsoir Vincent
est-ce que vous êtes là Vincent bonsoir
Elisabeth bonsoir à vous monsieur le
ministre Vincent normalement apparaît là
mais non là aujourd'hui voilà le voilà
bonjour bonsoir à vous Vincent votre
question au ministre
bonsoir Marco je voulais qu'on revienne
sur la note de Standard and port donc
qui est de AA et perspective négative
est-ce que il faut s'en satisfaire comme
l'a fait genre René Cazeneuve le
rapporteur du budget
est-ce qu'il y a pas encore quand même
des mesures à prendre pour améliorer
cette note
je sais pas ce qu'a dit Jean René
Cazeneuve que je connais bien qui est
très vigilant sur les questions
budgétaires c'est plutôt satisfaisant
qu'on est notre stable est-ce que ça
veut dire attendez
satisfait de cette de cette de cette on
peut à la fois dire que la note c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle parce qu'on
sait les effets que ça peut avoir sur
les taux mais ça ne veut pas dire nous
allons avoir des réunions avec tous les
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
pour regarder comment on tient notre
budget dans un cadre budgétaire la
réforme des retraites elle participe
d'ailleurs la Standard zen pour je le
dis
d'une tendance et d'une volonté
collective que nous avons de rétablir
les finances publiques de ce pays donc
c'est satisfaisant à tenter et sur le
temps long ça nécessite plutôt de
poursuivre l'effort plutôt que de le
relâcher et donc on a besoin de
continuer cet effort de déficience de la
de la de la dépense publique et de
réduction là où on peut de la dépense
publique
vous êtes satisfait Vincent alors où il
faut il faut concentrer cet effort
alors on est dans un travail qu'on fait
en interministériel de regarder il y a
un certain nombre de dépenses parfois
des dépenses fiscales qu'on ne peut
réorienter vers la vers des mesures en
termes de transition et écologique c'est
plutôt là qu'il faut le faire mais par
ailleurs il faut aussi assumer ce qui a
toujours assumé le président de la
République peut pas à la fois dire ça on
a le droit de programmation militaire on
a une loi de programmation de sécurité
intérieure on a des besoins en termes
d'éducation nationale et donc il faut
stimuler par une évolution de parfois de
la fiscalité et puis parfois faut
regarder dans chaque c'est pas moi qui
vais faire cet exercice là je le fais
pour ce qui est du ministère de
l'Agriculture actuellement de regarder
là où on peut avoir une défense une
dépense qui soit plus efficiente mais
référence de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
réforme des retraites le plus haut taux
d'emploi c'est une façon aussi de créer
de la richesse et de lutter contre le
déficit public merci beaucoup Vincent à
tout à l'heure bien sûr Yves très hard
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro bonsoir C'est à vous bonsoir
Elisabeth bonsoir Marc fenault alors ça
vous a pas échappé que la période était
quand même assez compliqué pendant cet
hiver avec avec la réforme des retraites
et on sent que le Président de la
République avait reconquérir le cœur de
l'opinion publique est-ce que si une
bonne façon de le faire non pas en
parlant du quotidien des françaises qui
fait quand même un peu mais beaucoup
d'histoires on voit que là il est dans
une séquence mémorielle aujourd'hui des
en train de célébrer les 1000 ans de la
l'abbaye de Mont-Saint-Michel au mois de
mai il a il a rendu hommage à Jean
Moulin et au Conseil national de la
Résistance demain il va sur les plages
du débarquement il y aura aussi un
hommage aux réseaux Manoukian à
l'occasion du 18 juin
vous croyez qu'en parlant aux Français
de la grandeur de la France de
l'histoire et de la mémoire on accroche
leur
leur vote je crois pas que ce soit la
volonté du Président de la République
d'abord les faits historiques s'imposent
à nous les 1000 ans du Mont-Saint-Michel
tomba pardon on n'est pas obligé de
célébrer non mais on peut considérer
qu'il y a quelque chose dans
l'inconscient objectifs en France la
Tour Eiffel le Mont-Saint-Michel
c'est pour ça que je suis très méfiant à
cet endroit de ceux qui veulent en
permanence revisiter l'histoire et nous
dire que c'est nous ne vont pas être
cher attendez une question je vous ai il
faut être fier ça fait partie c'est la
réponse à la Cancale culture et oui
on est le président de la République ils
nous autres qui sommes au gouvernement
et la majorité passe pas son temps à
essayer de répondre à la conception mais
que nous fassions notre chemin sur ce
qu'on pense être des données historiques
ce qui a été fait sur le Conseil
National de la Résistance c'est parce
que nous célébrions les 80 ans donc ça
c'est les faits historiques mais pour
avoir vu le président de la République
discuter avec lui encore qu'on nous
étions dans le Gard par exemple sur les
feux de forêt et sur la question des
moyens pour les feux de forêt c'est un
exemple c'est un exemple très concret je
peux vous garantir que dans le dialogue
que nous avons eu on a parlé plutôt de
sujets concrets sujets agricoles entre
autres si j'ai environnementaux plutôt
que mais on peut à la fois célébrer la
France dans ce cas-là dans son histoire
profonde à son histoire ça grande
histoire et en même temps s'occuper des
Français ce n'est pas antinomique et
voyez bien que sur beaucoup de sujets
sur les questions des retraites ils
étaient exprimés à plusieurs reprises il
y avait aujourd'hui un conseil national
de la refondation sur les questions de
logement avec un certain nombre de
mesures vous voyez bien qu'on peut faire
les deux sans se venir à chaque fois
dire alors quand il est sur un sujet
très concret on dit s'occupe de tout
quand il est à s'occuper de l'un et des
sujets historiques on dit il fait trop
d'histoires enfin il faudrait qu'on
essaie de simplement regarder de façon
tranquille le fait qu'il y a des moments
historiques qui sont assez libres parce
que c'est l'histoire de France et puis
ça m'empêche pas de s'occuper
parce que les dates historiques on les
connaît dites moi ce que vous voulez
savoir on voudrait savoir quand est-ce
qu'on commence cette réforme de
l'immigration ce texte de loi qui nous
est promis à intervalles réguliers dont
on connaît assez mal les contours avec
une première ministre qu'à pas l'air
très emballé par le dossier mais ça on
voudrait savoir par exemple mais c'est
ce qu'on va aborder le sujet
le ministre de l'Intérieur le ministre
du Travail Gérald Darmanin et Olivier du
soft travail à regarder comme on peut
avoir un texte qui puisse susciter
l'adhésion la plus large possible on
peut pas à la fois se dire vous ne
voulez pas écouter vous ne voulez pas
travailler avec les oppositions avec
Maître majorité donc quand on estimera
qu'on a quelque chose qui est un point
d'équilibre intéressant à ce moment-là
il pourrait y avoir le texte mais votre
problème c'est l'opposition à
l'intérieur de la majorité non d'accord
c'est pas une opposition on peut avoir
des débats donc enfin moi je l'ai dit
quand j'étais relation avec le Parlement
il faut qu'on accepte dans une majorité
mais aussi avec les oppositions de la
majorité relative qu'on puisse avoir des
débats essayer de trouver un chemin sur
ce sujet là c'est un sujet suffisamment
sérieux sur lequel tout le monde bute
depuis 40 ans pour qu'on essaie de se
dire est-ce que collectivement on peut
pas se dire voilà le train qu'on veut
avoir sans avoir en permanence des
virages d'une d'un quinquennat ou d'un
quinquennat à l'autre est-ce que vous
êtes est-ce que vous allez reprendre
certaines propositions de partie les
républicains notamment sur un changement
de la Constitution ou
sur d'autres dispositions qui vous
paraissent qui pourraient vous paraître
acceptable j'ai déjà beaucoup de sujets
donc mais je vais vous
le savez je peux être 360 degrés qu'on
essaie de regarder avec les républicains
quels sont les points d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui a été fait aussi dans le dialogue
qui peut y avoir avec le Sénat ces
sujets là après il y a des principes de
base c'est n'essayons pas d'engager des
sujets constitutionnels quand on sait
qu'on a pas de majorité
constitutionnelle n'essayons pas pas
nous l'opposition elle est non plus
essayons de ne pas nous affranchir des
traités européens c'est mieux moi je
pense quand on a des traités aussi
sensibles aussi difficiles sur lequel
tout le monde but depuis des années
d'essayer de trouver des chemins qui
sont des chemins crédibles parce que
sinon ceux qui nous regardent et qui
nous entendent ils disent à chaque fois
ils font du déclammatoire à chaque fois
ils promettent et à la fin on recule
donc le mieux c'est d'essayer de faire
en sorte qu'on essaye avec des LR avec
d'autres parce qu'il y a pas collé LR il
y a aussi peut-être sur la frange plus à
gauche de l'acide de l'hémicycle des
gens qui peuvent en conscience
considérer que nous sommes en situation
d'échec à la fois contre pour lutter
contre les fluides les flux migratoires
de clandestins
vous le dites ça le gouvernement est en
situation d'échec vous dites-le dire
mais nous sommes
collectivement je vois bien la
reformulation voulait me faire faire
mais je connais trop l'exercice j'ai pas
j'ai dit collectivement
l'objectif que nous assignons tous c'est
une difficulté la reconduite à la
frontière est un sujet complexe
l'intégration est un sujet complexe
alors il faut qu'on essaie de travailler
d'améliorer les choses est-ce que vous
si vous pensez que c'était parfois on
ferait pas de texte ministre de
l'Agriculture parce que vous êtes
concernés est-ce que dans les métiers en
tension il faut régulariser mais alors
c'est pas forcément seulement c'est ça
qui divise aussi mais c'est pas
forcément des sujets de régularisation
c'est aussi le faire en sorte que quand
on fait venir par exemple de la main
d'oeuvre de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée parfois c'est beaucoup de
la main d'oeuvre européenne donc c'est
un sujet d'une autre nature mais quand
on est sur des des travailleurs
saisonniers qui viennent de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée principalement de
qui sont pas dans l'espace Schengen de
faire en sorte qu'il soit bien ils
viennent bien pour le travail que ça ne
vient pas comment dirais alimenter le
comment dirais un flux migratoire qui
sont un flux migratoire de gens qui
s'installent dans la clandestinité si je
peux d'accord voilà alors est-ce que
vous seriez pas en mesure peut-être de
légiférer sur ce terrain avec un
gouvernement peut-être davantage
homogène avec une un premier ministre ou
une première ministre qui soit davantage
en phase avec le président de la
République sur ce sujet mais je ne vois
pas qu'il y ait pas de distorsion de
face en tout cas j'ai pas assisté je ne
crois pas que ce soit sujet c'est
trouver un point d'équilibre alors je
vois bien pour vous voulez me faire
rentrer dans
le moment joyeux que j'ai vécu plusieurs
fois qui est le moment où on spécule
parce que c'est souvent c'est souvent un
sujet
est souvent propice il nous a dit 100
jours
alors on a tous une imagination
galopante il a pas dit dans son jour on
change de gouvernement on change
de déployer une feuille de route sur un
certain nombre de sujets mais pas sur
l'immigration donc on est en train
d'essayer de trouver les conditions on
est en train d'essayer de trouver les
conditions de d'un chemin sur
l'immigration mais ce qu'on fait sur les
questions de logement sont faits sur des
questions de carbone et transitions
énergétiques c'est des sujets sur les
canons d'avancer ça faisait partie de la
feuille de route alors si une dernière
question dernière question alors on dit
on dit que vous êtes pas il y a beaucoup
de on dit vous savez dans le monde
ministère de l'Agriculture vous vous
pourriez changer je suis très heureux
mystère de l'agriculture d'abord il y a
quelque chose qui est toujours indécent
quand vous êtes ministre de dire vous
pourriez changer vous faire faire part
de de déshydrater quelconque c'est le
président de la République la première
ministre le Premier ministre qui décide
c'est la Constitution là aussi c'est les
règles de la 5e République très heureux
ministère de l'Agriculture pourquoi
parce que j'essaie de transformer
l'agriculture de mieux faire comprendre
à nos concitoyens ce qu'elle travaille
il y a toujours des bons esprits alors
j'adore le sous couvert d'anonymat et
nous sommes beaucoup de ministres avec
beaucoup de sous couverts d'anonymat il
y a toujours des bons esprits qui
ouvrent dans un journal un magazine avec
non sourcé non identifié et avec
[Rires]
pour les bottes mais on peut mettre
d'autres d'autres chaussures merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup frère comment on
fait pour manger moins de viande et
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on mange moins de
viande je vous dis ça parce que la Cour
des comptes alors à proposer une
solution radicale pour que la France
tienne ses engagements en matière
climatique elle pense que il faut
baisser les cheptels le nombre de
cheptel bovins qui représente environ
12% de ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre est-ce que cette proposition est
de bonne aloi est-ce qu'elle est
pertinente non mais je vais essayer de
dire quelque chose d'équilibré je l'ai
d'ailleurs dit au Sénat dans une réponse
aux questions gouvernement il faut lire
le rapport de la Cour des comptes parce
que je suis en désaccord il y a que deux
recommandations je suis en désaccord
avec les deux recommandations la
première c'est plutôt d'organiser une
forme de plan social et la deuxième
c'est d'organiser la décapitalisation du
chef peut-être français mais sur le
reste je trouve que ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur de ce document parce qu'il
faut d'abord faut jamais chahuter les
les institutions et je l'applique
moi-même comme ça je peux le dire aux
autres que ça serait mieux qu'il fasse
pareil y compris quand on a des
désaccords mais j'ai un désaccord sur
les recommandations mais il y a un
certain nombre de préconisations sur le
développement des élevages mixtes la
Cour des comptes dit par ailleurs que ce
serait bien que dans certaines zones on
développe plutôt l'élevage pourquoi
parce qu'on a besoin attendez réduire
les cheptels
on a besoin de remettre de l'élevage
dans certains zones pourquoi parce que
le
l'élevage on en a besoin pour se nourrir
on n'est pas autosuffisant sur aucune
des productions à l'exception du port
donc on peut si jamais on dit je
décapitalise et que la consommation
reste la même c'est l'importation que
vous organisez deuxième élément j'ai
besoin de l'agriculture parce que on a
évoqué on l'a pas évoqué mais il y a un
sujet par exemple autour des haies les S
et la biodiversité les c'est la
rétention d'eau c'est la lutte contre
l'érosion des sols il y a plutôt des
haies dans l'épisode d'élevage donc on a
besoin de valve la stratégie bas carbone
que nous avons c'est une stratégie de
maintien des prairies alors moi je veux
bien qu'on me dise à Carrefour mais si
vous supprimez l'élevage vous supprimez
les prairies et moi j'ai besoin des
éleveurs à la fois dans leur faction de
production pour pas de la viande de
l'extérieur ça veut pas dire qu'il y a
pas une tendance lourde qui est une
baisse de consommation de la viande que
deuxième élément on est en train
d'expérimenter c'est des travaux d'inra
et c'est pas moi qui le dit une
alimentation nouvelle à partir d'algues
je rentre pas dans le détail qui va
faire qui dont on dit l'inral est assez
surprise elle-même de des résultats
qu'on peut baisser de 20 à 30 % des
émissions de méthane en particulier et
donc il faut qu'on travaille plutôt
là-dessus et par ailleurs on a besoin de
décarboner la fertilisation en bio la
fertilisation des carbonées c'est quoi
c'est l'élevage bon il faut se garder
des idées vous mangez de la viande oui
je mange de la viande
[Musique]
agriculture de la perdre rouge et de la
viande
je ne sais pas si c'est le cas
Jean-Claude Tissot merci de nous avoir
rejoint et d'avoir accepté monsieur le
ministre et monsieur le sénateur
socialiste de la loi le principe du
débat on va revenir sur deux sujets
qu'on a un peu abordés et d'abord on
commence par les pesticides monsieur
Tissot alors allez-y c'est
[Musique]
le plan est confitaux les confitaux 1
les confitures 2 on a dépensé 700
millions d'euros quels sont les
résultats vous venez d'annoncer un plan
écofyto 3 et donc ma question elle va
être très simple qu'y a-t-il dans ce
plan Écophyto 3 qui va pouvoir inverser
la tendance parce que quand on parle de
pesticides certes on parle on pense à
l'agriculture mais vous pensez aussi
à tous tous les dégâts collatéraux des
pesticides c'est à dire essentiellement
alors pardon parce que c'est un faut pas
que ce soit non plus un échange de
d'initié inversé la tendance pour que
l'usage et le recours aux pesticides
soient infiniment moins important dans
l'agriculture française donc c'est votre
question et on écoute la réponse
aujourd'hui on est quand même 32% au
dessus de la moyenne européenne la
consommation française de pesticides en
2% au dessus de la moyenne alors c'est
une mauvaise note alors est-ce que
d'abord je peux je peux deux secondes
sur phosphine et asmeto la chlor qu'on
soit au clair parce que alors ce sont
deux pesticides l'un est un insecticide
l'autre est un herbicide l'imperva
désherber l'autre sert sur la fausse
fine c'est un sujet très simple c'est
une molécule qui est interdite sur
l'espace européen qui est autorisé en
revanche en dérogation pour les pays qui
sont importateurs de céréales
au sud de la Méditerranée par exemple
qui demande sof à ne pas pouvoir
importer chez eux exporter chez eux de
la fausse fine tous les pays d'Europe
activent cela il m'a semblé qu'en
conscience dans le moment de crise qu'on
traverse avec une crise alimentaire
mondiale avec un problème de sécurité
alimentaire je considère que dans
l'urgence dans laquelle nous sommes et
comme c'est une demande des pays
d'accueil de ces céréales pourquoi ils
veulent de la fausse fine parce qu'ils
veulent pas que des insectes venant de
chez nous viennent sur leur territoire
c'est aussi simple que ça et donc c'est
leur préconisations qu'on applique et
donc ce qu'on trouve un jour des
alternatives j'ai aucune difficulté avec
ça mais
ça dépend des produits ça dépend des
produits mais sur les il y a des sujets
qui sont plus simples c'est plus
compliqué reconnaissant le sur des
herbicides que sur d'autres produits
mais je n'en rabat pas sur la volonté
mais je n'en rabatterai jamais sur
l'idée que quand même si jamais on peut
pas nourrir ces pays-là c'est d'autres
qui le feront en particulier monsieur
Poutine et je pense qu'on partagera ce
point de vue et que donc en conscience
on a besoin de le faire et sur le smeto
la clore la seule chose que j'ai demandé
j'ai pas remis en cause
jamais l'analyse scientifique j'ai juste
dit que ça serait jamais vous ne me
verrez je vous assure croyez-moi
pas se faire un concours de bonne foi je
crois qu'on est plutôt sincère dans nos
expressions sur le S métaux la chlore le
sujet c'était de dire est-ce qu'on peut
pas le synchroniser avec le calendrier
européen voilà il va y avoir bientôt une
décision européenne je trouvais que
c'était c'était pas indécent de dire ça
parce que ce qu'on interdit chez nous on
peut pas l'interdire de produits venant
d'Allemagne d'Italie ou d'Espagne donc
c'est 20 ce qu'on fait si jamais on fait
des choses on n'arrive pas à monter les
sujets au niveau européen et y compris
par exemple sur un certain nombre de
réglementations européennes je suis pour
qu'on ait une réglementation européenne
et qu'elle soit éventuellement plus
ambitieuse mais qu'elle soit au niveau
européen sinon c'est la France qui perd
et vous l'avez vu en attendant
c'est quelque chose qui est né du
Grenelle de l'environnement ça fait donc
bientôt
là aussi je disais sur un autre sujet
tout à l'heure reconnaissons qu'on n'est
pas au rendez-vous de la promesse
collective que nous avions formulé mais
tout le monde doit prendre sa part dans
son exercice j'ai pas dit que vous la
prenez pas mais je suis comptable de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et chacun doit
dire que pourquoi on a été en situation
d'échec pour deux sujets on n'a pas mis
d'argent sur la recherche et dans le
plan France 2030 on met plus d'un
milliard d'euros sur la recherche parce
que la seule solution c'est de trouver
des alternatives mais alors pour le
coupage carrément mais sauf que chaque
loi de finance mais là on les a la
recherche sur la recherche le budget de
l'inrae est quand même quatre fois moins
le but
et quatre fois moins important que le
budget de recherche de Bayer vous irez
demander vous irez vous irez demander à
l'inrae s'il pense qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
pas fait un saut quantitatif et donc
avec derrière un saut qualitatif sur les
moyens de la recherche mais ce retard là
ça fait 20 ans qu'on l'accumule je
prends l'exemple de de néonicotinoïde
puisque vous étiez sénateur et vous
aviez vous aviez refusé la dérogation
supplémentaire on vote cette loi là en
2014 si j'ai bonne mémoire
d'interdiction des néonicotines en
France on a mis quasiment le meilleur
moyen sur la recherche pendant 5 ou 6
ans et donc on s'est retrouvé je fais
griller à faire personne c'est la
situation dont on a l'impression et donc
on a besoin pour faire quelque chose qui
marche mieux dans les cophytos de mettre
les moyens sur la recherche et la
recherche d'alternative et de poser les
choses en termes de planification et moi
j'ai demandé c'est ce qu'avait dit la
première ministre ou quoi si on
l'agriculture je veux qu'on sorte toutes
les molécules quelles sont les risques
qui sont associés quels sont les
alternatives qu'on a quels sont les
impasses qu'on a et qu'est-ce qu'on
cherche pour essayer de sortir est-ce
que vous êtes convaincus parce que ce
que disait monsieur Tissot dans le fond
c'est qu'il y a toujours des bonnes
raisons pour ne pas faire voilà c'est ça
vraiment productive efficace votre
sincérité mais en fait vous essayez de
trouver une solution sans changer de
modèle et aujourd'hui force est de
constater qu'on est au bout du bout du
modèle on est au bout du modèle
complètement chimique un modèle qui a
sorti la France de l'ornière a sorti de
la guerre
14-45 bien évidemment il fallait nourrir
voilà vous connaissent tous l'histoire
mais aujourd'hui on est plus dans ce
modèle là et aujourd'hui moi ce qu'on
peut vous reprocher et peut-être que
dans le plan Écophyto il faudra voir de
quelle manière ça peut s'organiser sur
les années qui arrivent mais en tout cas
il faut absolument encourager et vous
parliez du bio tout à l'heure il faut
encourager une agriculture alternative
et une agriculture alternative
permettez-moi juste de vous dire que
c'est vous avez tenu ses propres là
c'est pas obligatoirement être amis
c'est pas obligatoirement être
Emmanuel Macron c'est pas oui pardon
c'est pas le sujet
réfléchir autrement mais être sur la
sobriété c'est pas obligatoirement être
un décroissant ça veut dire on réfléchit
autrement et on réfléchit à la manière
dont on pourrait se passer des produits
phytos ça veut dire quoi vous parliez
tout à l'heure des des insecticides des
herbicides mais on peut s'en passer des
herbicides on peut c'est une autre façon
culturelle c'est-à-dire quoi des
rotations culturelles différentes du nom
labour il y a plein de solutions
techniques et on sait que c'est une
solution aujourd'hui existent et marche
sauf que et là pour le coup je vais
peut-être être un petit peu
plaisir on a pas le temps même il y a
quand même il y a quand même une force
un lobby très très fort dans
l'agriculture en amont sur la lavance
les fournisseurs les les semenciers les
les les bailleurs compagnie et confrères
qui qui qui qui fournissent tous ces
produits
moi je voudrais pas vous céder aux siret
de ces gens-là
ce modèle alternatif mais je suis
d'accord avec l'idée qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de faire évoluer le modèle je dis
simplement j'avais encore les quelques
jours les producteurs de cerises on a
interdit des molécules dis mais toi oui
et on a eu raison d'interdire le dimetho
non mais voyez-vous me trouvez pas sur
un autre chemin simplement aujourd'hui
on est en impasse technique voilà donc
on a 30 à 40% des rectangles il y a pas
d'alternative sinon changer de modèle et
on n'a pas besoin de produits alternatif
non mais il faut qu'on trouve si on a
besoin de produits par exemple sur la
cerise un dispositif qui s'appelle
l'insecte stérile c'est un truc tout à
fait c'est du ce qu'on appelle du
biocontrôle mais si le sujet c'est de
revenir à un moment où on peut avoir ce
qui a été avant la guerre de 40 et bien
avant c'est-à-dire des crises de
maladies des crises d'insectes qui fasse
qu'on fasse disparaître les récoltes
qu'est-ce qu'on a gagné on a rien gagné
donc on a besoin de changer de faire
évoluer le modèle mais on a besoin de le
faire pour continuer va pouvoir produire
parce que qu'est-ce qui se passe en
France par exemple sur les fruits et
légumes on était autosuffisant il y a 20
ans résultat des courses on est à 50 %
d'autosuffisance qu'est-ce que je gagne
si je peux plus produire de cerise donc
j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de ça c'est pas
faux oui c'est pas faux le constat
évidemment je pars je le constat mais
c'est pas parce qu'on utilise moins de
pesticides ou plus de pesticides qu'on a
qu'on produit moins de légumes c'est pas
du tout le problème
mais je n'ai pas dit que c'était que ça
mais je dis ça fait partie des facteurs
et je ne dis pas ré homologuons des
pesticides ont été interdits je dis
juste il faut trouver des solutions
alternatives parce que si la seule
perspective que je donne un producteur
de cerise c'est tous les ans d'être
indemnisés de la perte parce que la
drosophile qui a attaqué ses cerises il
arrêtera de produire des cerises parce
que les agriculteurs les arboriculteurs
et les autres ils ont pas envie de
produire pour perdre parce que c'est du
gaspillage ça c'est ce qu'on appelle du
gaspillage alimentaire n'est pas une
solution vous savez que le principal
gaspillage alimentaire il n'est pas dans
nos frigos le principal gaspillage
alimentaire c'est les récoltes qu'on
perd
dans le monde et y compris chez nous
c'est parce qu'on a pas de main d'oeuvre
ou parce qu'on n'a pas de produit y
compris des produits qui soient plus
respectueux de l'environnement les
outils de biocontrôle sont des éléments
importants vous avez parlé de la
question des semenciers il faudra qu'on
aura un débat à jour sur la question des
semences mais il y a des nouvelles
techniques qui ne sont pas des OGM ils
sont pas les nouvelles techniques
génomiques qui permettent d'accélérer
les processus de sélection si vous avez
des variétés qui sont plus résistantes à
telle ou telle maladie on va gagner
notre temps et quand on a ça ça permet
de moins utiliser tel produit donc c'est
ça dont on a besoin alors ce que je veux
dire par là c'est on est d'accord sur
l'idée qu'il faut faire évoluer le
modèle j'ai aucune difficulté avec ça
simplement le faire évoluer c'est pas ce
que vous avez fait donc je veux pas
caricaturer votre propos en disant on a
les solutions vous avez parlé de la
technique de dire sans labour la
technique sans labour pour beaucoup
d'entre elles elle est elle est basée
sur l'utilisation minime et
l'utilisation de pesticides
si vous voulez qu'on parle dans la
sécheresse il nous reste cinq minutes
c'est maintenant monsieur Tissot alors
allez-y
tu vois ces choses moi j'ai une question
fondamentale vous posez une chemise mais
vraiment fondamental aujourd'hui si on
part du principe ou le l'eau est un bien
commun de l'humanité et je pense qu'on
est tous d'accord pour pour dire ça et
d'autres personnes l'ont dit mais bien
avant nous comment peut-on se résoudre à
accepter que que quelques-uns puissent
subtiliser
ce bien commun sans se poser la question
qui est fondamentale comment c'est
quelques personnes rendent à l'humanité
alors quelques-uns c'est qui je veux
dire prendre l'exemple de sainte Soline
c'est pas pour polémiquer mais parce que
tout le monde connaît bien ce problème
là on fait une grande bassine on pompe
dans la nappe phréatique on remplit
cette grande bassine qui va servir qu'à
quelques-uns c'est-à-dire qu'à quelques
producteurs et et on prend un bien
commun comment ce bien commun on le rend
et je m'adresse
c'est une question
je réponds d'abord quand vous prélevez
de l'eau en l'agriculture c'est vous le
savez parce que vous êtes du métier ou
prélevez pas de l'eau pour remplir votre
piscine ou nettoyer votre d'accord bien
sûr
produire un bien commun
parce que l'alimentation c'est un bien
commun
quand vous prenez de l'eau pour arroser
des tomates non mais de la du maïs qui
peut servir à l'alimentation animale
vous prenez de l'eau pour le bien commun
qui est alimentaire alors quelle est la
question qui a derrière sur lequel je
peux partager et je vais reprendre
l'exemple de sainte-soly parce que c'est
un bon exemple ou un exemple de mauvaise
polémique sainte-solide c'était 21
millions de mètres cubes prélevés tous
les étés le modèle qui a été construit
avec beaucoup plus d'agriculteurs
d'ailleurs qui sont tombés c'est des
centaines d'agriculteurs même si
d'autres mais pour des raisons
topographiques ils ont moins accès c'est
à la fin 13 millions qui seront prélevés
dont si seulement on était donc on va
passer de 20 millions de mètres cubes
prélevés l'été à 6 millions de mètres
cubes donc il y a un effort de fait ça
veut dire que le projet était pas si
bien mais si le projet est bien
puisqu'on va réduire la consommation au
départ et deuxième élément oui mais
maintenant il est signé il y a un
protocole tout le monde était d'accord
et donc il faut avancer et les
agriculteurs ils sont engagés sur quoi
sur une modification de la seulement sur
une réduction l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires et ça pourrait être
contrôlé et sur la plantation de haie et
donc si le seul perspective que vous
donnez au monde agricole c'est
débrouillez vous sans eau ah non j'ai
jamais dit ça
c'est tragique et donc il y a des
endroits où c'est des réserves de
subtilités
qui s'imposent aucune plante ne pousse
sans eau nous sommes dans
les tomates pouvaient pousser sans eau
je pense pas dans la vraie vie on est
bien d'accord il faut de la pierre et de
l'eau voilà voilà donc après pour
revenir
à la problématique du stockage de l'eau
alors il y a des solutions des retenues
colinéaires etc mais il faut quand même
juste savoir que quand on retient 100 on
a 100 qui se disparaît on a dès qu'on
extrait de l'eau du sol et qu'on le met
dans une bassine on a 30 % des
performances et à nouveau votre question
parce qu'on arrive à la fin monsieur
Tissot et à nouveau quand on asperge on
on irrigue on repère donc ma question
est très claire comment faites-vous pour
encourager comment vous aider finalement
c'est ça financièrement vous encourager
des systèmes alternatifs du
goutte-à-goutte et seulement et
seulement aux productions qui apportent
une plus-value parce que si c'est pour
un rosier de l'herbe qui qu'on va donner
à des vaches que ces vaches vont faire
du lait et qu'on vend le lait à 350
euros la tonne ça ne sert à rien nous
sommes en réponse en deux minutes si
c'est possible pas de souci comment
faire ou Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale simplement je partage l'idée
que c'est on doit gérer en commun cette
affaire là c'est à dire que c'est pas
l'affaire des uns c'est pas l'affaire de
ceux qui pour le tourisme sans occupe de
ceux qui en ont besoin pour l'industrie
donc on a besoin de réfléchir en commun
je suis d'ailleurs assez favorable à
vous c'est possible c'est pas c'est pas
le cas dans les à sainte-soulines mais
d'avoir des ouvrages qui soient
multi-usages qui puissent servir
l'alimentation en octobre le meilleur
exemple c'est Serre-Ponçon bien sûr mais
serpent sont aujourd'hui les détracteurs
que vous avez là sur la table ils
refuserait Serre-Ponçon la vérité c'est
ça mais oui il vous dirait que on vient
parce qu'on est sur un cours d'eau c'est
un poisson orpansion c'est un modèle qui
marche y compris en partage et donc on a
besoin simplement de dire aux
agriculteurs voilà ce qu'on les ouvrages
qu'on vous autorise mais c'est
simplement ça se fait dans le cadre
d'une transition du modèle
y compris pour dire c'est plutôt cette
culture qui est priorisée y compris sur
les efforts de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires y compris ce qu'on a
fait sur Samsung et donc faut plutôt
encourager la transition l'accès à l'eau
il doit être comment dirais-je organiser
pour faire en sorte qu'il permette la
transition et pas qu'il accélère des
processus de
pression sur l'eau qui soit trop fort
vous voyez bien qu'il y a des modèles on
voit bien qu'il y a des modèles dans
certains pays du monde compris en Europe
où on a trop prélevé d'eau et le système
s'effondre c'est pas le modèle qu'on a
en France et donc c'est celui-là qu'on
doit privilégier et de ce point de vue
là on a une gestion collective et
commune c'est à dire le penser que c'est
pour tout le monde qu'on le fait y
compris en terme d'alimentation oui ou
non
en suivant en tout cas c'était
passionnant merci beaucoup on est prêt
ça avance merci mais restez avec nous on
va écouter maintenant Vincent roux qu'on
retrouve au firewlive Vincent quel est
votre question au ministre
oui bonjour rebonsoir Marcelo il y a une
affaire qui a pas mal émue ce week-end
c'est l'agression d'un petit garçon qui
s'appelle Kenzo 8 ans c'était lors d'un
match en marche d'un match Ajaccio om ou
des des supporters des hooligans se sont
introduits dans sa loge on frappait son
père et on agressé également cet enfant
qui est handicapé ce soir Emmanuel
Macron a dit au Mont-Saint-Michel qui
voulait des sanctions claires et fortes
on en attendait pas moins mais est-ce
que vous pensez que ce genre de de
discours suffit à arrêter cette
ces violences est-ce qu'il faut pas des
mesures vraiment plus radicales des
mesures d'interdiction de stade
notamment pour un certain nombre de
supporters et de fictionnados mais enfin
les mesures d'interdiction seront
produites dès lors qu'on va identifier
les enfin je crois qu'ils sont en cours
d'identification les coupables de ces
actes donc ça c'est une chose
l'interdiction ça d'être une mesure la
justice doit
sans relâche ces éléments là merci
beaucoup d'avoir posé cette question
Vincent qui nous renvoie à l'ensemble
des violences avec une espèce de loi des
séries ces dernières semaines qui est
tout à fait stupéfiante et sidérante et
qui nous interpelle tous Merci à vous
monsieur le ministre d'avoir été
l'invité ce soir merci Monsieur Tissot
encore une fois d'avoir accepté le
principe du débat c'était très
intéressant on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à 19h30 pour audition publique
bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]